اذا هذه المشاهد التي تابعناها لغرق
الكثير من الاراضي بالتاكيد سيكون لها
تداعياتها على سير المعارك خاصه مع
الشواهد على بدء الهجوم المضاد فالمياه
اغرقت الكثير من التحصينات الميدانيه
الروسيه طبعا نتحدث عن الخنادق والمخابه
التي كانت مباشره مقابل هذا النهر والتي
صممت للحمايه من اي تحركات اوكرانيه عبر
النهر طبعا معهد دراسات الحرب الامريكيه
قال ان الانفجار اثر بشكل اكبر على الطرف
الذي تسيطر عليه روسيا تحديدا من نهر نظرا
لانخفاض الضفه على هذا الجانب قياده
العمليات الجنوبيه الاوكرانيه قالت ان
القوات الروسيه نقلت افرادها ومعداتها
العسكريه الى مسافه تبعد خمسه عشر
كيلومترا من منطقه الفيضانات ما يضع
القوات الروسيه خارج مرمى نيران القوات
الاوكرانيه على الضفه الاخرى قال معهد
الدراسات حرب ان القوات الاوكرانيه على
الجانب الغربي من النهر اجبرت على اخلاقي
او اخلاقي مناطقها تحت النيران المدفعيه
من القوات الروسيه على الجانب الشرقي من
النهر ويرجح خبراء ان الجانبين لن يطور
المعارك الى حد كبير في انتظار انخفاض
مستوى المياه قبل اتخاذ خطواتهما
الميدانيه المقبله في الطرف الاوكراني
تبدو فكره عبور النهر خيارا غير مرجح نظرا
للصعوبه وايضا لتكلفه العمليه اضافه
لافتقار اوكرانيا للقدرات البرمائيه لكن
النقطه الايجابيه مشاهدينا بالنسبه للجانب
الاوكراني هي ان الفيضانات بدات بالفعل
تجرف التحصينات وحقول الالغام التي
اقامتها القوات الروسيه في تلك المنطقه
ومع ذلك لن يكون التاثير النهائي للفيضان
في ساحه المعركه واضحا لعده ايام او ربما
اسابيع
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات